present the award for the best film of
the year we welcome the star whose glow
has dazzled us since she entered films
before she entered her teens winner for
the Oscar for a starring role in a
farmer's daughter and our abiding
admiration for hundreds of other
performances and romance and comedy
adventure and drama here is Miss Loretta
Young
reality is the main quality that most
creative filmmakers seek to achieve in
their work they believe it's a vital
ingredient innocent to the success of a
motion picture
fortunately reality contrary to some
beliefs is not restricted to sorted or
shocking themes nor gritty gutter
language nor gratuitous violence etc
reality is also healthy wholesome love
and romance is courage adventure
inspiration and heroism this year some
tasteful filmmakers have rediscovered
that fact and I am delighted for one and
we are all of us enriched because of it
these then are the five nominations for
the Best Motion Picture of 1981 Atlantic
City it's an international international
cinema corporations
caramel Denis Eric and John Kemeny
production their producers next is
Chariots of Fire in aiding a production
manager the lad company Warner Brothers
David Puttnam
and ITC films ipeec Films production
Universal and Bruce Gilbert producing
these Raiders of the Lost Ark it's a
Lucasfilm production of paramount Frank
Marshall producer
Red's a jrx production pheromone
one day they produce
the winner is Chariots of Fire
just for 30 seconds I wish I was better
the most extraordinary generous people
on God's earth not just Academy to whom
have to be head thankful for this but as
a country to have taken what is
absolutely a Cinderella picture and
awarded it this you come to st. in
droves is absolutely extraordinary I got
many your indulgence this is a Best Film
Award and three and a half years ago I
started out with Colin Welland and the
director Hugh Hudson could he please
stand with me we've been together three
and a half years I'd hate not to be now
I had to thank I've been away to start
it starts with my good friend sandy
Leverson who made it possible in the
first place everybody at 20th Century
Fox Mohammad and Dodi Fayed who came
through for us and put their money where
my mouth was and since coming here
warner brothers in the lab company for
falling in love with a pool and
literally it's thanks to them and waited
tonight thank you very very much
you